ولايه رئاسيه ثالثه غير مسبوقه لرئيس
الصيني بعد تصويت المجلس التشريعي الذي
يسيطر عليه الحزب الشيوعي بالاجماع على
ابقائه رئيسا للبلاد الولايه الثالثه
لجيجي بنج لن تكون سهله امامه تحديات عده
في عهده تصاعد التوتر بين الصين والغرب
بسبب ضغط بكين المتزايد على تايوان
وتقاربها مع روسيا خطط الرئيس الصيني لم
تستبعد استئناف المحادثات مع واشنطن لحل
التوترات لكنها محدثه حذره حتى اللحظه
يطمح الرئيس الصيني بان تنافس بلاده القوى
العظمى لاسيما امريكا مع سعيه ايضا الى
انعاش اقتصادي بلاده المتعثر اثراء ازمات
عده خطوات يتبعها
ليحول الصين لبلد اكثر هيمنه عبر تشكيل
حكومه جديده لاحياء النمو وحمايتها من
التهديدات
الداخليه والخارجيه اضافه لمساعي بالتحكم
في المخاطر الماليه وتشجيع الابتكار
العلمي المحلي كي يتمكن من الاستغناء عن
خبرات الغرب ويقلل الاعتماد الخارجي ويحصن
الصين من اي تهديدات تطالوا انها الغذائي
والطاقه